yeah I'm making almost double than way I
make it my full-time job too so how long
should it be going well for for you to
be able to take the plunge like six
months two months a year so it it's
continually asking the question man what
business model could I build around this
and there's so
many so I've had this channel for a year
now I've been on YouTube four years so
this is my second Channel I pivoted to
this and it's gone really well in a year
and when I was here last time I asked
you about going full-time when I wasn't
even really close to going full-time
like I was making a little bit of money
a month and um that's when we talked
about you know when you had said when I
made about 25% of you know that magic
number than to quit and go for it well
I'm now making about 80% of that magic
number and I'm still scared to go
fulltime no but this is we gotta
celebrate this is coffee that is crazy
so and it's cool totally I totally
remember us talking and I was like
you're way closer than you realize yeah
you said that so it was how much do you
need per month to pay pay your bills and
I said when you're at 25% you should go
all in did you go all in no no no I'm
scared so now but so now you've really
supplemented those so that means there's
quite a bit of abundance because you
have your main thing and this thing's
doing 80% of that so you have a little
bit of extra yeah I'm making almost
double then way I make it my full-time
job too so but but the one thing I
didn't ask and that I was confused about
was like I it's been going well for two
months you know and do so that didn't
occur to me back then like how long
should it going well for for you to be
able to take the plunge like six months
two months a year you know like I know
YouTube and I mainly rely on AdSense I
don't really have much else going on yet
but I am looking into memberships and
merchandise and all the other income
streams but um so maybe I should get a
couple of those going first but you had
said that my AdSense would probably be a
huge part for my channel because of the
way it was going then and I'm getting
lots of views and my RPM is pretty good
yes so I'm just kind of I don't know if
I'm I've never run a business before
I've been I've had a government job for
20 years right so I'm like you know it's
great talking to all the people in the
elite because there some business owners
there are giving me some advice but I
thought it would be great to get your
take on it where I am now this is a fun
conversation
so first of all I know I said you know
go all in at 25% but the way you're
doing it sounds a little bit like how I
would do it which I like I like being
conservative I like
taking I lean on the extra solid path
rather than jump out when you like are
$1 when you have $1 enough of abundance
versus a little bit of a cushion a
little bit of savings to answer your
question specifically how long should
things be going well I think there's
something about having six months of
consistent results I think that's
interesting you said there's two months
so there's something
about um seeing six months the better
answer would be 12 because there's
something about learning
Cycles we can have a Black Swan Event
Event like c19 which is not even a cycle
is a total out leer but cycles of
holidays cycles of UPS cycles of downs
one of the things that's been
interesting to observe is some people
are discouraged by their views being
down on YouTube right now overall
comparing it to the era they remember of
2020 2021 when people were so locked
down and on their phones all the time
now we are really seeing a return to
shopping malls outdoors and no doubt
about it I mean YouTube is getting
zillions of views and shorts are getting
zillions of views so it's not like
there's there's so a lot of people uh
consuming but there was an ERA during
coid when it was like 10 times higher
than it was right now what's my point
the longer of Cycles you can see the
better I think also the better that the
longer you double your income like
you're doing right now the bigger the
cushion you can create and so I think
that's it's always incredibly wise to
have cash
reserves um to have a six-month
emergency fund so that also would give
you some peace of mind is not just to
have if you will doubled your income but
to have your monthly needed amount of
income six months reserved liquid now
you can survive Cycles because you're
like okay well half the year things are
really good to me it would seem your
subject matter is entertaining 20 you
know 247 365 but some of those
conservative moves would be very wise
emergency fund keep doing what you're
doing if you're finding it sustainable
how's your sleep and energy and rest
going with maintaining both it's it's
been difficult yeah um but I actually
recently um because I've wanted to get
more videos out like it takes me about
two to three weeks to get a video out
and I've recently hired a friend of mine
to do some research for me because
that's a huge part of it so that's
helping so I'm able to do that give her
a few hours a week and um it's making a
big difference this is the first week
I'm doing it but yeah it's like you're
running on both ends right trying to
keep the channel going and keep it
engaging and keep videos going but
luckily people are watching you know
like I don't post for three weeks but
I'm still getting the same amount of
views you know that I was when I posted
the last time so it's going well now but
I just you know you never know if it's
going to continue the same rate and
that's the other buffer for the YouTube
Creator which was also similar to my
goal earlier on we were doing one of our
coaching sessions and I was talking
about um
to Jenna that she should get five to 10
ranked
videos um for you too I think you know
this two months old is still getting 28
views this three months old's still
getting 50 views per hour this five
months old's getting 343 views per hour
obviously we talked about last time it
would be nice if you could just do this
every time and print videos like this
but you are definitely in a different
position if over your next 50 videos 10
of them are have this kind of Baseline
if you had 10 videos working for you
getting you 343 views per hour we
oftentimes call a good YouTube video an
employee that you pay once that works
for you for weeks months and years to
come you have to you have to pay because
like you said you pay with your time
your energy it takes so long to make
these powerful stories but once you've
done the work if all goes well this
video literally works for you for the
next couple years paying you ad Revenue
even though you don't touch it
so the oversimplified answer to the
conversation is just keep doing what
you're doing honestly like it's entirely
up to you when you can tolerate how much
comfort do you want before jumping out
how much um you know stability do you
want and that brings me to I
think one thing that you could start
exploring would be this idea of brand
deals
potentially or this idea of asking what
business model could you connect to this
so I like to think about like
uh if there's maybe something you
personally love um
and would get behind and let's say it
was something that was like paracord or
something like you know and and you try
to think about how much broad appeal
could it have so this is like a really
cool premium paracord handmade leather
camera
strap um and it so maybe it could be
some kind of a pocket knife it could be
some kind of a thing and this is this is
up to you right what I'm talking about
is what could you sell what could serve
your audience what could people that are
interested in maybe adventuring
themselves um what could something be
that's truly that you could be proud of
a friend of mine actually runs a company
that helps creators it's called prouduct
as in like a product you're proud of
especially when you think about
sometimes white labeling lowquality
products from um Ali Express
versus what if you what if there was
something that that was that
irresistible like oh I got to buy that
oh 25 bucks I got to buy that and
imagine if so there so when we think
about ultimately advertising on YouTube
it's going to come down to a really
simple equation end of the day no matter
everybody watching this is all selling
something even the people that are
uncomfortable with sales everybody
watching this is selling
something what YouTube is created is
people giving their attention by
watching videos and one of two things
are going to be sold maybe multiple
things number one if you go I just want
ad Revenue I just want people to
advertise on my videos you have to
consider and this would be very true for
you
Stacy you're putting in you're making
many documentaries you are probably I
would argue you're probably one of the
lowest paid documentary filmmakers in
the world right
nowc because you're putting out these
Masterpiece stories of research and the
thumbnail and you're putting the whole
thing together and you're getting paid
on ad Revenue it's a big blessing
but the attention you're getting for
YouTube the
platform is allowing them to put ads on
your videos split the revenue with you
but the people putting ads on your
videos they're all selling something
they're they're selling a product a
service a car something so that the Deep
question that should maybe trouble us at
night here at coffee with canel is
simply asking hey wait a minute why am I
not selling something you know the end
of the day and and chances are if smart
advertisers were advertising on your
videos they would understand that the
people interested in your content might
be into Outdoors might be into these
different might be into like maybe some
natural living so they could buy some
bison meat that's dried and they could
have it shipped to your house because
all the nutrition you're going to get
and what are they gonna sell they're
going to sell bison meat on your videos
Patagonia is gonna advertise on your
videos like whatever yeah Northface was
one of the ad
yeah
so so then as you evolve that's while
you're brainstorming you got a lot to do
to create your videos you've got you
still got the full-time job but you can
decide what is it I want to build and
what do I want to set up
because um don't underestimate for you
Stacy and everybody watching this
whether even if your Channel's small you
getting any attention in at all is
incredibly valuable and do you trust
your viewers you know in the hands of
advertisers well sure it's their
decision to make or or do you want to
serve them in whatever way possible so
again that could be merch it could be a
motto eventually you you put on a
t-shirt it could be a c you know
different things and you don't have to
launch that immediately but all I'm
saying is now you have Diversified your
business and it's much more stable if
you were to say Sean I'm gonna quit my
job what's your plan add
Revenue there's people who are making
that work but if for some reason YouTube
got offended and they demonetized your
Channel or whatever you would you'd just
be in a vulnerable spot so it it's
continually asking the question man what
business model could I build around this
and there's so many there's a lot of
aligned products there could be
education related stuff there could be
travel related stuff partnership with a
travel company brand deals with outdoor
stuff travel companies um you will sleep
more peacefully at night when you know
you're
Diversified yeah I think that's it is
that's key and uh my biggest fear like
you said is the demonetization like I've
had one I've had a couple things come
through where they limited my ads on one
video and then I appealed it and then it
went back to normal but one stayed so
and it's one that's getting a lot of
views right now so that you know dropped
to like zero Revenue so that's my
biggest fear and I try and really watch
it I don't know why that one got limited
ads got try and not post anything that
was it kind of because of violence or
because of serious well it was at Mount
Everest video and um in it I you know
people die on Mount Everest I'm talking
about death and stuff and at one point I
think I showed her body like the
person's body like it was frozen and you
know covered up and stuff but it was
being moved like really briefly in the
video and that's the only thing I can
think of that might have been offensive
in there but some of the stuff you see
on YouTube I'm like that's tame compared
to some stuff that I see so yeah and
learning those that all of these are
the we can land the plane here let's
look up the
definition of the word
entrepreneur so the you and everybody
watching this even if you wouldn't
consider yourself an entrepreneur by
simply setting out to start a YouTube
channel um that you know pays you
full-time um to be To Be Your Own Boss
to work for yourself here's the
definition of an entrepreneur it's a
person who organ izes and operates a
business or businesses multiple taking
on greater than normal Financial risks
in order to do so there it is yeah so a
lot of us in general might
be uh risk averse um you might say Sean
I would totally do this except for it's
scary it feels risky yeah yeah that's
what entrepreneurship is well I feel I
feel kind of Uncertain it feels like it
has less ability than you know if I just
stayed in my 9
to5 yeah that it this is the definition
like greater than normal Financial Risk
what is normal normal is the median
normal is the average the average person
does want to stay comfortable wants to
avoid risk wants to avoid doing
something different but ultimately the
person who Ventures out into the Creator
economy and by the way organizes and
operates a business so that mental shift
from just having a hobby channel to like
no I am a business operator I'm a
Creator CEO check uh chief executive
operator Who Am G to organize and plan
and structure and think about even
though I don't know what it is what is
my product what is my sales what is my
marketing what is my business who does
my business need what kind of money does
my business need what will it take to
scale this thing and I'm going to take
on greater than normal Financial Risk to
do so um and a lot of times when things
start feeling risky uncertain unsteady
welcome to the party like I mean that's
where what we signed up for I mean
that's and
so calculated risks I think is a key um
taking risks but making sure you don't
bet the entire Farm because sometimes
you win and sometimes you learn
losses as painful as they may be can be
education in
entrepreneurship to you it might
be blurring out um you know something
like a body describing it like just
learning you know what how can I
communicate powerful stories but also
stay safe within you know YouTube's
guidelines but we're not going to be
able to avoid those kinds of things
there will be videos you launch that
maybe get demonetized and it's super
discouraging because you're like I I
lost out on hundreds or maybe thousands
of dollars but maybe you gain 10,000
subscribers and you learn from it like
it's risky it's the nature of things um
that video actually you talk about one
video changing your channel and that one
launched like catapulted my channel
because it brought in so many new
viewers and they all started watching my
old videos which why that femon old
video is picking up so it's really
changed the trajectory just that one
video and so if it's demonetized it's
fine I'm fine with that yeah totally
fine because that's a great mindset to
have because it's still growth still
subscribers which can watch other videos
and and the Futures forward any final
final questions I can answer for you no
I think that's it you you talking about
the 12 month cycle that's huge that I'd
never thought of that before but that's
something I haven't been through yet
because the Channel's so new so I think
that's going to be my plan is to do it
for a year and see and then I think I'll
feel really comfortable if I've been
doing well for a year you know doing it
on just a couple months makes me really
nervous uh quitting the job so I think a
year's plan is a great thing to go with
if you enjoyed this podcast and are
ready for some deep dive YouTube
strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my
1hour OnDemand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com